is it in Trump unleashing on the media
over reports the Russians paid bounties
for killing American troops the
president saying it is a fake news hoax
that is meant to damage him politically
this didn't rise to the occasion and
from what I hear and I hear it pretty
good the intelligence people didn't even
many of them didn't believe it happened
at all I think it's a hoax I think it's
a hoax by the newspapers and the
Democrats right Brian kill me what's
your take on that well I think to blow
it out of proportion the way they have
as if we didn't know that the Iranians
the Taliban were trying to kill
Americans for free because it's their
life mission for 19 years that's the
story if it was happening in Canada
that's a story but in Afghanistan our
guys being targeted
that's called Tuesday and for the
Russians to be behind it
okay worth pursuing but to say this I
talked to two people that were in that
meeting and they say that there was
there was a dissent to that in the
president's brief which is why it didn't
enter to the verbal part of the briefing
Danny used to tell me how President Bush
want to get briefed every day but a lot
of it was verbal President Obama
famously wanted to read it all himself
and then get maybe the highlights on the
verbal briefing this president likes it
a little bit different but if you just
go down and see what the president's
doing to Russia and the favors he got
back the favors he got back zero what
has he done
cracked down on the natural gas movement
and into into natural gas as it goes
into Europe of course the the treaty
said he's left and the Obama and the
Obama administration what do they do
when they first walked in without asking
they took out the missile shield in
Eastern Europe and said can we be
friends
vitamin Putin said don't think so okay
but Katie it why not just say we're
looking into it there's dissent in the
Intel community and I want to get more
information I'm and the gang of eight is
gonna be briefed tomorrow and said you
almost egging on the whoever the leaker
is to do more of it
well it seems like that was what White
has practiced press secretary Kaley
Mackin and he was trying to do today
from the podium at the beginning of her
briefing saying yes the gang of eight
will be briefed the intelligence is
still disputed I think the president is
just as frustrated because the
implication from the punditry and the
press is that he knew about this and
therefore did not do anything about it
because he is somehow in bed with the
Russian government which plays into this
narrative that he's been facing for
three years through the Moller
investigation and through other leaks in
the intelligence community now does that
not mean that we should as a country be
very concerned about what Russia is
doing in Afghanistan and the links and
connections that have been there for a
long time with the funding that Russia
has been giving to the Taliban and maybe
what it was used for of course but I
think the frustration from the
administration comes from this
implication that President Trump knew
about it and purposely didn't do
anything because sometime somehow tied
down to the Russian government
Donna politicizing intelligence it's not
new but it is disgusting it's an
important I think even for someone
especially like for Vice President Biden
who lived with intelligence briefings
for eight years during the Obama
administration to be exceptionally
cautious at this point until we know
more but that's not the direction they
decided to take why you know I do
believe in a situation like this it's
been five days and we've had five
different explanations everything from
the intelafone didn't spell it out and
big bold black letters with a marker and
of course we've also heard that it was
it was not part of the oral briefing but
it was in the written work we've had so
many excuses so much finger-pointing and
then of course we got to bring up barack
obama and joe biden and george w bush
and what they did the president just
needs to reassure the American people
and the family members of our troops our
veterans the people who are sacrificing
for us that he is looking into this
situation but he has their back period
just just tell us that you gone look
into this situation you go make sure
that you have verifiable information and
if this is true what
the Iranians the Pakistanis are the
Russians you're not
this is unacceptable and you're going to
deal with it that's all you have to do
and then let's get on to the next battle
yeah and Jesse one of the reasons that
politicizing intelligence is so
dangerous is that it it puts a president
a commander-in-chief into a position of
having to deal with something publicly
that may have been dealing with
privately in a different way and there
might be people in harm's way
you know we don't know all the answers
to this a gang of Eight's going to be
briefed tomorrow but I'm kind of hoping
there's not additional leaks out of that
give me the final word permission to
make a sports analogy Dana sure so the
Democrats run an offense and they run
the same play every single time it's an
out and up and everybody just bites on
the pump fake and gets burned deep every
single time are we seriously talking
about an anonymous leak from the
intelligence community to the New York
Times that makes Trump looks like he's
in bed with Vladimir Putin are we
seriously going to do this all over
again
like they even use the same three
reporters that they used on the rush of
collusion hooks at the New York Times
and like don't get me started what about
WMDs in Iraq do you remember the
intelligence from that they used one guy
the source remember what his name was
curveball aptly named curveball he
actually lied to the US and said that
Saddam had WMDs and then when he didn't
he said oh you know what I made that up
because I wanted you to topple Saddam so
listen I don't know if it's accurate
intelligence I'm open-minded we don't
know and I do know this the people that
benefit from this leak the Democrats
politically the new york times
financially russia geopolitically
because they want us tied down in
afghanistan and so to the defense
contractors in the hawks so just keep an
open mind about when you hear about an
intelligence leak that you read in The
New York Times that makes Trump look bad
it's about our troops Jesse pump-fake
it's about our troops it's not about
you're gonna have to explain your
threats don't bite on the face Russia
attacks us I know